[Music]
oh it's friday it means time for
friday follies an impeachment edition
joining us with all the details raymond
arroyo fox news contributor all right
raymond
you saw a moment at the trial last night
that told a bigger story it did when
when the final questions came laura for
the house prosecutors
jerry nadler moved as fast as he's ever
moved to answer
even when lead manager adam schiff tried
to stop him
any other comments the senate would
benefit from hearing
before we adjourn for the evening
mr chief justice members of the senate
jerry jerry jerry it reminded me of
another team that
also kind of fell apart had a big
falling out laura
no that's all i asked no listen all
right no it's just there i'm only here
raymond raymond both east jerry's had
enough of that shift
okay what happened here you'll remember
nancy pelosi is really to blame for this
animosity between these men
jerry nadler as head of the judiciary
committee he should have been the first
prime mover on impeachment
she put her friend and her accomplished
shift to lead the
not only the impeachment but to guide
the he wanted to be shiftless
well and then you remember when nadler
got up he made those horrible comments
to the senator saying this is a
torturous vote
traitorous vote that set off alarms and
then
nadler the nadler hustle may have been
payback for this moment at oppressor
last week
mr mr nadler the republicans have been
going
i'm going to respond to the questions mr
nadler has been criticized by
republicans mr shirley
i'm going to respond to the questions
and adler had to just sit back and take
it
let me tell you it didn't matter whether
schiff or nadler led this thing
or who was driving the bus there wasn't
enough gas to get it where they wanted
it to go
it's over but it shows you the tension
and the animosity and i noticed there's
something about
adam schiff when he gets a little bit uh
exercised about something no his eyes
get really he
he does that marty feldman eyes just
stand a little bit yeah
since this impeachment began the media
has taken up well the democrat line
and they're trying to characterize the
proceedings this way
any other comments the senate would
benefit from hearing before we adjourn
for the evening
mr chief justice members that was the
wrong but
it was actually they were talking about
this being a solemn
serious well i'm not sure senator kamala
harris
got the memo watch chuck schumer's
reaction when kamala was a little less
than
solomon serious do you view it as at
least a partial
victory that you have a republican like
sorry uh i'll start again do you view it
as
at least a partial victory start against
everybody
solo oh no no yeah let's let's cut that
out from the
report so comment i'm surprised kamala
didn't break into that remember how she
did that dance
song and dance yeah that dance tape the
bob marley routine now laura there was a
moment that
frankly it made me pretty sad when i
watched this the senate chaplain barry
black
opened the senate trial with this prayer
listen closely
remind our senators that
they alone are accountable
to you for their conduct
lord help them to remember
that they can't ignore you
and get away with it for
we always reap
what we sow now if you're going to
condemn people
and raise the the judgment of god to
them
don't do it over a partisan thing like
this impeachment this is divisive
he should be bringing people together
i'm sorry i think the chaplain went
above and beyond the number
he said earlier in the week uh the trial
will make the nation stronger wiser and
better
how raise your moral voice for things
that matter
abortion religious liberty that's worth
conscience all right raymond before we
go
they say a picture is worth a thousand
words yes they do
um but is it really the case is
do we see the faces of what it all looks
like at the end
oh so sad this was after the the senate
voted laura
no witnesses oh oh very dejected
she looks happy imagine having a drink
with her tonight
won't you help this anchor this is like
a save the children
right you know the old factory line
laura the world is a looking glass and
gives back to every man
what his face shows god help some of
these folks
i hope they have happier days